there is no higher form of user
validation than having customers support
your product with their wallets but the
path to a profitable business is not
always an easy one to help you choose
the best monetization strategy Google
and Udacity have created app
monetization an online course that
presents strategies and best practices
on how to make your apps profitable this
course includes viewpoints from
e-commerce to games and insights from
leading startups in multiple industries
by the end of this course you'll be able
to choose and implement a monetization
strategy relevant to your product set
performance metrics and monitor the
success of a strategy and know when to
pivot your existing monetization
strategy so what are you waiting for for
more information visit
udacity.com/google